[Music]
and haunted hotel news no I always think
of that every time because I'm a [ __ ]
what makes you think that you are so
[ __ ] special that you are always
gonna get because she has people that
have passed I love her so they would
want to come back and visit her - yeah
but that's a good thing then that's not
haunting then I would like brown of this
okay so you know what makes me fall oh
that is so tight yeah you know what
makes me feel better there's this TV
state earth show like an old one where
this man said if any of you [ __ ]
supernatural people can prove it for
sure I'll give me a thousand dollars
till this day after like decades they
still haven't been able it was a million
dollars I think yeah a million bucks his
name is James Randi there's a Netflix
about him yeah they were never able to
prove it so so he said what is he did
he's like I'm not paying you
I grew up Mexican I'm sure you guys
didn't know I don't even know what that
means doesn't [ __ ] the cool stuff we
have like a super ghost and then there's
always a house that like I swear you
have at least like five relatives that
tell you that they grew up in a house
that was haunted and somebody pulled a
[ __ ] foot am I wrong oh you're not
like we gonna let you being a ghost Oh
have you seen one that's I said I grew
up Mexican but I'm not or you have like
ghost experiences and I know I sure have
even in my own house they'll say I'm
pretty sure they're [ __ ] with me
that's not probably scared but they're
like yeah there's disappearance we have
a long hallway my mom said like yeah
there's a spirit that crosses your room
into my pantry both sides all the girls
if there's an emergency exit here too
much sense in here this is Jill's room
you put over your face in there you go
visiting a famously haunted hotel
captured a soda that's that's a
wonderful name why would you name it
that like why don't you even be scared
of that it's all because we came up with
the Spanish words I mean like if I was a
kid and someone told me there's a lot
that smells like quit making up Spanish
[ __ ] whatever laughs you're like Bobby
Hill's mom I know
hey that's not españa is expunged Oh
community your joke was so good and
everybody's Joe that's [ __ ] don't Kim
Jeong jeong's character well cuz he's a
Spanish teacher and he just makes up
[ __ ] yeah like Bobby Hill's mom yeah
[Music]
Bobby's mom is like she's so she swears
she knows Spanish and she comes in
pictures like the hill yeah she's always
whole lot everybody lot Espanola
that's not she is but she's a Spanish
but she's so stubborn
oh she's banished teacher there's an
episode where she took their kids to
Mexico and then she got in trouble
because she kidnapped the Mexican kid
right and brought to the bus and tried
to smuggle over him not really but she
had to prove herself in the court and
she goes no I don't need a lawyer I'm
gonna defend myself and she spoke her
broke ass Spanish and I let her go what
the [ __ ] she's doing okay so back to the
ghost talk this hotel where they
captured this interesting
it's at the Stanley Hotel in Colorado
which is the exact same
it's a we've been there oh we've been
there that case is coming through this
there because it's [ __ ] haunted we're
visiting one of our bars opera gate
athletes and that place has that feeling
though it looks like a [ __ ] you know
that that like old looking hotel like on
a mountain like and it's kind of creepy
it's not like that movie with the two
twins on the bicycle no I'm gonna get to
that
I took your dreams the hotel inspired
this shiny yes yeah we're there yeah yes
so they they won 108 year old hotel it
is if you guys don't know what the
shining in is a movie about a she stayed
at this hotel he had a nightmare and
then that's what drove him to have or to
make this novel yeah so this have a a
spirit tour at this hotel because it's
very haunted why are you laughing
his we're so stupid we were like we've
been there yeah that's why they got some
bomb-ass fried Brussels sprouts bone
tell me the scary story
I [ __ ] hate Brussels sprouts me any
type of me too but this was good because
I would rather have a fried something
else okay focus muck it's muggy cuz I
love Brussels but anyway here dumb and
dumber
I just want to see a picture oh it
doesn't let me walk down good cowboy
outfit Aspen yeah in Aspen alright here
we go
so it's an Inside Edition oh yes our
favorite yeah cuz they break the real
news your sense because it's JKD show
you come on I'm such a great with that
[ __ ] it's fine [ __ ] said okay
while walking around they snapped this
photo and at the bottom of the image was
something
see in person even if you look at the
picture you notice nobody's looking
there you know they're all looking at
the tour guide so I mean you just don't
excuse something like that you worry
it's the scary like the jammers
last year another guest tried to snap a
blue jersey lobby but ended up with a
photo of what looks to be a woman at the
top of a staircase
I like how they had to switch the
exercise soundtrack and just like a
couple notes for copyright do you want
me to let your imaginations go wild or
break it down break it down okay
obviously fun obviously okay Kukui
master completely from the start do you
guys see the lighting in that place
there's so much [ __ ] spotlights
with the lines going right yeah there's
so many of those letters cuz it's not
the flip there's so many lights there
that are doing that thing that it's
warping the [ __ ] cameraman 100%
that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] spot from when he
jacked off with this phone and the light
hit it and that's how you got it I see
arms though I don't see [ __ ] I see a
bowling pin shape how do you know it's a
her and there's so many genders now
don't do it don't bother shave me it
looks like a dead squid and if it's a
[ __ ] wet goes she was like she's
wearing [ __ ] cortezes or at back to
imagination time I was having this
thought right modern buildings like the
cool ones like like your apartment that
you lived in downtown LA how come they
don't have haunted [ __ ] and if they do
are they like freshly dead people so
they're like modern and they have cool
clothes and stuff so I could go show up
with joggers on or something yeah or
like hipsters and [ __ ] you know so
they're not that scary you know recently
I've been reading into astral projection
and what the [ __ ] is that Doctor Strange
apparently this is a real thing that you
can really do but I don't know so they
tell you how to do it and pretty much
you have to lay down and just relax and
you have to be like on the border of
like your mind is or your body's falling
asleep but your minds awake kind of
thing
and then you you tell your yourself to
like you picture your hand to move and
like your spirit moves or whatever
slowly you get yourself out of your own
body and you get to like just explore
the astral plane and they're saying that
if you get good enough in it that you
can actually communicate with spirits
that are in this ring oh we can't be
friends anymore I do I want to know your
stories nice and hang out all you gotta
do is do I Alaska everybody knows that
astral plane itself you ain't got a
practice can you go find Tyson and give
him a hug I don't know but they are
saying that and also they were saying
that you can go through like anywhere in
the world
Crom serious I'm not gonna hang out with
you anymore that means you're gonna
bring back spirits I keep telling you
you're not that special
I would haunt you geo I had a classmate
that was about fifty years old and he
looked like the really fat version of
the beaver and a vendetta Matty near the
V for Vendetta mask I didn't like Bobby
no no these I know my lips [ __ ]
tripped all right
the Korean buddy for Panetta beaver
bandana
okay imagine this guy alright he's like
you know the the anonymous mask yeah
it's like that but the fat guy version
long hair got the [ __ ] greasy jheri
curl and he's got a curly mustache right
so I don't know how he was my classmate
in college but he was and we were
playing not playing but we were this was
a ceramics class so you were doing yeah
and this fool he was so [ __ ] weird
and I think he did that astral
projection [ __ ]
because like you would have these
inspirations and then he's like normal
and in yoga so the other day when I was
going through this plane I was speaking
to epic Nezzer
and also the great barrows and what they
told me and then everyone was like
discuss [ __ ] scary dude and they were
likely here
and then it was really weird but I think
he was an astral projector do it I
couldn't pay attention to your story cuz
all I picture was a scene from coast so
the other day ride hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode did you love
it I know you did but guess what you can
also follow us on our personal social
media account with the links in the
description box below so go follow all
of us now to watch more videos check
about up there
[Music]